[موسيقى]
في مناخ من اعدام الثقه المتزايد وتنام
المشاعر المعاديه لفرنسا زار الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون مطلع هذا الشهر 4
دول افريقيه زياره جاءت بعد يومين من خطاب
مطول القاه في الاليزي كشف فيه عن
استراتيجيته الجديده من اجل ما سماها
علاقه اكثر توازنا واكثر انسجابا مع
حاجيات الدول الافريقيه واولوياتها خصوصا
في مجالات التنميه الاقتصاديه والصحه
والزراعه والامن الغذائي
يريد الرئيس ماكرون طيه صفحه الماضي
والانتكاسات التي عانت منها بلاده في
منطقه الساحل اعتمادا هذه المره على القوه
الناعمه لاصلاح صوره بلاده الاخره في
التدهور ولا سيما في اوساط الجيل الجديد
من الساسه الافارقه فما هي الملامح
الرئيسيه لهذه الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه
الجديده في التعامل مع دول القاره السمراء
وهل تستطيع باريس استرجاع نفوذها في ظل
تزايد النفوذين الصيني والروسي في المنطقه
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله بينما تستمر
المشاعر المعاديه للوجود الفرنسي في
اكتساب المزيد من الزخم في العديد من
البلدان الافريقيه يصر الرئيس الفرنسي على
رغبته في تطوير شراكات جديده في مجالات
متعدده بعيدا عن التدخلات في الشان
السياسي والاقتصادي لهذه البلدان عن
الشراكه الجديده التي يريدها الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون وفرص نجاحها في ظل منافسه
شرسه على النفوذ في افريقيا تقودها قوى
دوليه واقليميه يسعدنا ان نستضيف من باريس
السيد توما جاسيو النائب في البرلمان
الفرنسي ورئيس لجنه الدفاع الوطني فيه ومن
مدينه في جنوب افريقيا الدكتور محمد
النظيف يوسف عضو البرلمان التشادي وبرلمان
عموم افريقيا ومعنا من مدينه في المانيا
الكاتب الصحفي الاستاذ منصف السليمي
مع بدء فتره ولاياته الثانيه شرع الرئيس
الفرنسي في اعاده ترتيب اوراق سياساته
الخارجيه خصوصا في العلاقات مع البلدان
الافريقيه التي كانت تمثل الحديقه الخلفيه
لمواقع نفوذ فرنسا الرئيسيه ما دفعه الى
الاعلان عن ملامح رؤيته الجديده التي يمكن
تلخيصها في نقاط رئيسيه هي تقليص عدد
القوات العسكريه القواعد العسكريه
الفرنسيه واداره بعضها بشكل مشترك مع
الدول الافريقيه التي توجد فيها تلك
القواعد وتحويل بعضها الى اكاديميات
عسكريه لتدريب الجنود الافارقه خفض عدد
الجنود الفرنسيين في عدد من دول القاره
وخصوصا في منطقه الساحل الافريقي والجنوب
الصحراء تقويه الروابط الاقتصاديه
والثقافيه والتركيز على مشاريع التنميه
والاحتياجات الانسانيه وتسهيل التاشيرات
للطلاب الافارقه ودعموا القطاع الرياضي
واخيرا التوسع في العلاقات مع الدول
الناطقه بالانجليزيه مثل كينيا وغانا
ونيجي ريا او الناطقه بالبرتغاليه كاجولا
الخطاب الاخير الذي اعلن فيه الرئيس
ماكرون رؤيته للشراكه الجديده مع افريقيا
يتماهى في مضمونه مع خطاب اخر القاه قبل
نحو ست سنوات امام الطلبه في جامعه في
جامعه وجادوجو في بوركينا فاسو بعد سته
اشهر فقط من توليه الرئاسه وفي هذا الخطاب
اعرب عن رغبته في طي صفحه الماضي وبشر
بسياسه فرنسيه جديده تركز على الشباب
الافريقي وبعد تلك الزياره باربعه اعوام
عقد مؤتمر القمه الافريقيه الفرنسي الجديد
في مدينه مومبلي الفرنسيه في الثامن من
اكتوبر عام 2021 تحت عنوان من اجل العمل
على اعاده صياغه العلاقه بين افريقيا
وفرنسا لم يشارك في المؤتمر اي رئيس لدوله
باستثناء ماكرون ذاته الذي القى خطابا
امام الشبان الحاضرين قال فيه انه يريد
اعطاء الاولويه لشباب هذه الدول ولكل
الذين يصنعون التغيير في القاره السمراء
وفي فرنسا
[موسيقى]
هذا موقف يختصر التحول في الذهنيه
الافريقيه بشان العلاقه مع فرنسا في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي يطالب رئيس جمهوريه
الكونغو الديمقراطيه
باريس في رده على سؤال صحفيه فرنسيه بعدم
التعامل بابويه مع الدول الافريقيه لم يكن
معهودا في ازمنه مضت ان يخاطب قاده افارقه
باريس في حضره رئيس فرنسي بهذه النبره
ولان فرنسا ايقنت ذلك سلفا جاءت الجوله
التي قادت ماكرون الى اربع دول افريقيه
بدايه الشهر الجاري على امل اقناع
الافارقه باستراتيجيه باريس الجديده تجاه
القاره
وباحصاء 18 زياره للرئيس الفرنسي الى
افريقيا منذ توليه الرئاسه تذهب قراءات
الى ان الرجل يخوض معركه وجود في هذه
القاره التي كانت الفناء الخلفيه لفرنسا
لكنها لم تعد كذلك بتوسع نفوذ منا فسين
جدد في مقدمتهم روسيا والصين
يروج الخطاب الرسمي الفرنسي الاستراتيجيته
الجديده القائمه على تقليص البعد العسكري
في العلاقات مع افريقيا
فلفرنسا قواعد عسكريه رئيسيه دائمه في كل
من كوت ديفوار والسنغال والغابون ورغم
تقليص تعدادهم السنه الماضيه ما يزال الى
الان نحو ثلاثه الاف جندي فرنسي منتشرين
في منطقه الساحل الافريقي لا سيما في
النيجر وتشاد بهدف دعم الشراكه العسكريه
بين فرنسا ودول الساحل حسب هيئه الاركان
الفرنسيه
وهناك ايضا قاعده جيبوتي قرب مضيق باب
المندب الاستراتيجي وتستضيف اضخم قاعده
عسكريه فرنسيه في الخارج
يرفض ما يسميها المنافسه الاستراتيجيه
التي يفرضها في افريقيا من يستقرون هناك
مع جيوشهم ومرتزقتهم وفق تعبيره تلك اشاره
واضحه لروسيا بعد تعاظم دور ميليشيا فاجنر
في دول افريقيه عده منها مالي وافريقيا
الوسطى
وهناك ايضا العملاق الصيني الذي يتوسع
اقتصاديا ويتعاون عسكريا مع دول القاره
يقدم البلدان نفسيهما شريكا استراتيجيا
بديلا عن الدور التاريخي لفرنسا
وهذا ما جعل ماكرون يستنجد بالشركات
الخاصه من بلاده تحت غطاء زياده الاستثمار
في قطاعات الصحه والزراعه والتعليم
لاستعاده ما يمكن من مناطق النفوذ الفرنسي
نجدد الترحيب بضيوفنا الثلاثه من باريس
وميدران في جنوب افريقيا ومن مدينه بون في
المانيا وسؤالنا النائب في البرلمان
الفرنسي ورئيس لجنه الدفاع الوطني في
سيتوما هل يمكن اعتبار فعلا خطاب ماكرون
الاخير
معبرا عن رغبه حقيقيه لدى فرنسا لتغيير
مقاربتها في العلاقات الفرنسيه الافريقيه
ام مجرد اعاده انتاج لبعض الخطابات التي
قالها اسلافه ثم ذهبت ادراج الرياح كما
جاء قبل ذلك في خطابات فرنسا واولاند
والرئيس سالكوزي
خطاب الرئيس الجمهوريه ينطلق من رغبه
برحله جديده فكما تعلم هناك شراكه جديده
اطلقت وهناك امور كثيره جرائم جازها خاصه
مثلا زياد التقليل حضور العسكري
وتقليل الذكريات الاستعماريه كل هذا يدل
على الرغبه في التقدم الى الامام لاصلاح
الشراكه بين فرنسا وافريقيا لن نعرف ان
افريقيا افريقيا قاره مختلفه جدا فيعصى في
المغرب وفي
غرب اوروبيه او شرقها تختلف من بلد لاخر
فرنسا تتمنى ان تواصل اصلاح التعاون بين
فرنسا وكل الدول الافريقيه يعني في حتى
نفهم فعلا ابعاد هذه العلاقه الجديده التي
تتحدث عنها ويتحدث عنها الرئيس ماكرون
الرئيس ماكرون في السابع والعشرين فبراير
شباط الماضي القى خطابا تحدث فيه عن ضروره
تخلي فرنسا عن اللهجه المتعاليه والتعامل
بالتواضع مع الشركاء الافريقيين كما سماهم
ثم جاء بعد ذلك في المؤتمر الصحفي مع
الرئيس الكونغولي واستخدم ذات اللهجه
المتعاليه التي انتقدها من قبل كيف يمكن
اقامه علاقات شراكه نديه ومتوازنه مع من
يقول الشيء ويفعل نقيضه
كله كله اعتقد ان اللهجه لم تكن
استعلائيه بل على العكس كان يريد ان ينطلق
ويواصل شراكه وتعاون نديه
ويرى ان افريقيا هي بلد
الفرص وليس الاستعمار وايضا كنا كحده في
الحلول تقدمها فرنسا
والشراكه التي يمكن ان تنتجر مع دول
مختلفه وهي شراكه يمكن ان تكون اقتصاديه
واقتصاديه وثقافيه وامنيه وخاصه مجال
الامني هناك رغبه كبيره في تغيير الموقف
ان ننسحب من الخطوط الاماميه وانا حاول
مساعده الدول الافريقيه واستجابه لطلباتهم
ومرافقتهم باكبر قدر ممكن حسب طلباتهم حسب
ما يرغبون
الدكتور محمد النظيف يوسف هل يتقبل في
رايك المزاج الافريقي في هذه المرحله
الحرجه في العلاقات بين الجانبين الفرنسي
والافريقي الدخول في شراكه جديده وفق رؤيه
ماكرون
اعتقد بان ليست شراكه جديده وانما فعلا
لابد من هيكله جديده
للعلاقات بين فرنسا
وافريقيا ادركت فرنسا نفوزها في افريقيا
بدا في تقلص
وتيره سريعه
لعده عوامل من ضمنها عدم تناسب شكل
الهيمنه الفرنسيه على سياسات واقتصاديات
هذه الدول مع المتغيرات والتطورات الحديثه
في عالم اليوم وكذلك لا بد من الهيكل
الجديده لان هناك وجود اجيال جديده من
الشباب لا تملك كما قال زميلي في البرلمان
الفرنسي لا تملك الارتباط الوجدانيه
والثقافي مع فرنسا مقارنه مع الاجيال التي
عاشت الاستعمار بعض الاستعمار في ظل
الانفتاح على
الثقافات الاخرى ايضا لابد من الهيكل
الجديده لنا برزت برز هناك اجيال جديده من
القيادات السياسيه
والعسكريه الشابه التي ترغب في تغيير او
في البعض حتى القطيعه مع الماضي
الاستعماري
وايضا الناس يذهبون موضوع النفوس كما
ذكرتم لا بد من الهيكل النفوس الصيني
الدور الذي يركزه على العمران وعلى
التنميه وانا شاربت في 2016 في مدينه
جانسبورت هنا القمه الصينيه الافريقيه
والفين 2018 في بكين القمه الافريقيه جاء
جميع العفاريقه رئيس واحد بس ماجه 53 رئيس
كله وصل الى بيكين اذا فرنسا ومع خلق
روسيا مناطق كما تعلم في افريقيا لابد من
حيكل جديده وموضوع التقليص استيعاب
المهاجرين الافارقه وكما ذكرتم في التقرير
موضوع الطلبه هذه الاشياء كلها لابد من
فرنسا تعيد هيكله
علاقاتها مع الدول الافريقيه علاقه
النديان وعلاقه الشراكه الحقيقيه تقول
لابد من اعاده هيكله هذه العلاقات ما
الخلل الموجود في العلاقات القائمه حتى
تعاد هيكلتها
لماذا الشركات الاخرى البعيده جدا اللي ما
عندها علاقات مع فرنسا تاريخيه تاتي وتقدم
خدمات
لماذا هذا
سيد منصف اسلامي في اواخر خمسينيات القرن
الماضي تجرا سياسي شاب من غينيا على
الجنرال شارد جول واعلن امامه رغبه بلاده
في الاستقلال الكامل عن فرنسا واداره
سياساتها النقديه بما يتوافق مع السياده
الوطنيه المعمول بها في كل البلدان
المستقله كان نتيجه ذلك ان اقدمت فرنسا
على معاقبه بلاده بشكل كامل غينيا اغرقتها
بالعملات المزوره ونالت من الاقتصاد
الكيني وامرت الفرنسيين الذين كانوا
يعيشون الذين كانوا يعيشون في كينيا هل
تسمعني
السيد منصف سليمه هل تسمعني
يبدو ان هناك مشكله في التواصل مع السيد
منصف السليمي
دعنا او دعونا ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام نتوجه
بالسؤال
للسيد تومه النائب في البرلمان الفرنسي
الى حين اصلاح هذه الخلل في التواصل مع
السيد منصف اسلامي سيد السؤال ذاته حينما
تجرا السياسي الشاب في ذلك الوقت احمد
سيكوتوريا على انتقاد شكل العلاقه مع
فرنسا والمطالبه بالاستقلال التام حدثت
المعاقبه الشديده لبلاده غينيا حتى تكون
عبره لكل البلدان الرغبه في الاستقلال عن
الهيمنه الفرنسيه الان تجرا ايضا الرئيس
الكونغولي وقال اوجه كلاما للرئيس مكرون
مشابها لما كان قد قاله السيد
سيكوري قبل نحو نصف قرن او اكثر من نصف
قرن ولكن لم نرى رده الفعل الفرنسيه
القويه كما حدث في الماضي ما الذي تغير
منذ ذلك الحين حتى اللحظه الراهنه كيف
تراجع وانحصر نفوذ فرنسا بهذه الصوره
انا شاهدت
مقابله مع الرئيس المقابله للرئيسين
الكونغولي والفرنسي ولم اجد ما يدعو الا
انتقاد شديد او لم اسمع انتقادنا شديدا
لكن في العلاقات بين الرئيسين هي في
الواقع علاقات جيده جدا وعلى العكس من ذلك
انسان يتحدثان ندا لنده
والرئيس الكونغولي
قد تتجرا عن ان
ياخذ هذه العلاقه مع رئيس الصيني مثلا
في فرنسا يمكن يمكن ان نقول الاشياء عينك
عين بعين وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان فرنسا
والدول الافريقيه لديهم تاريخ طويل مشترك
وجغرافيا وقريب بعض اقل من 20 كيلو متر
تفصل اوروبا عن افريقيا
واننا نرى ان هناك علاقه جديده او نسعي
نحو علاقه جديده مع الدوله الافريقيه منذ
2007 وهناك الكثير لكن مع ذلك هناك كثير
العادات القديمه التي في الجانب روسيا
والافريقي ما زالت قائمه لابد من التخلص
منها وان ان منذ 2019 بدات موجه جديده من
العلاق لكنها لم تدخل كل
النفوس في هذا الشهر بين الشركاء
افريقيا تبقى
ارض فرص واننا دعمها في الازمات وان
الرئيس الفرنسي ارقى خطابا في فرنسا
لتعبئه المجتمع الفرنسي ليقول لهم ان
افريقيا هي ارض رائعه
للفرص ولا بد من مضاعفه استثماراتنا هناك
وايضا لدينا تحديات كبير لابد ان نواجهها
خاصه تحديات
التغيرات المناخيه وبالتالي تتحدث عن عن
اهميه الغابات الموجوده في افريقيا والتي
مهمه جدا في الظروف الكولاجيه الخاصه
نعود مجددا الى ضيفنا من مدينه بون في
المانيا الكاتبه الصحفي الاستاذ منصف
السليمي ارجو ان تكون تسمعني هذه المره
بشكل واضح سيد منصف يتحدث ضيفنا من باريس
عن علاقه نديه وعلاقه تماثل وصداقه بين
الرئيس الفرنسي ولبرائه الافريقيين وانما
جرى من الرئيس الكونغولي لم يكن تقريعا
للرئيس الفرنسي ولم يكن القاء محاضرات
عليه في طريقه التعامل او في اسلوب
التعامل الامثل بين الشركاء هل ترى الامر
على نفس الشكل
في حقيقه الامر المشهد الذي دار بين
الرئيسين يعكس الى حد ما المعضله التي
تواجهها فرنسا في خطابها لافريقيا سواء
الرئيس ماكرون او فرنسا بشكل عام فرنسا
تريد ان تظهر وجه جديد لسياساتها
ودبلوماسياتها في القاره الافريقيه لكن
القاره الافريقيه
لديها انتظارات ولديها ايضا نظره لفرنسا
واعتقد ان فرنسا هي التي تواجه معضله لان
التطور الذي يحدث في افريقيا سواء على
المستوى الداخلي على المستوى النخب على
مستوى السياسات على مستوى التوجهات على
مستوى المجتمعات وكذلك الادوار الاخرى
القوى الاخرى التي تدخل على الخط في
القاره الافريقيه اي المنافسه لفرنسا هي
تظهر ان هنالك فجوه كبيره بين تطلعات
فرنسا ومحاولاتها لتغيير سياساتها
واستراتيجيتها وبين واقع الامر ولذلك
اعتقد ان ذلك المشهد بين الرئيسين
يعكس الى حد ما هذه الفجوه واعتقد ان في
العمق فرنسا الان تكافح من اجل الحفاظ على
وجودها في فرنسا هي في افريقيا هي في
معركه وجود في حقيقه الامر
واعتقد انا مقومات الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه
الان لا اعتقد انها قادره على انها تجعلها
تستعيد نفوذها حتى
ما الذي يعوض هذه الجهود وما الذي يعوق
اعاده فرنسا استعاده استراتيجياتها
المتبعه في افريقيا لزخمها المعتاد
في حقيقه الامر فرنسا تتوفر على اوراق
استراتيجيه وتاريخيه وبشريه مهمه جدا
للتاثير والنفوذ في القاره الافريقيه لكن
هذه الاوراق تلعب مثل العمله ذات الوجهين
تلعب دورا ايجابيا وسلبيا لكن دعنا نبدا
بواحده اعتقد ان فرنسا على امتداد عقود
وامتداد اكثر من قرن من الاستعمار وما بعد
الاستقلالات وموجات الاستقلال من
الاربعينات ثم الخمسينات والستينات
تاتي الان في البعد في 2023 تريد ان تضع
سياسه جديده دون ان تضع نقدا ذاتيا عميقا
لسياستها
السابق لسياساتها السابقه ولا اتحدث عن
نقد ذاتي عادي وانما عن القيام مثلا
باعتذار عن الفترات الاستعماريه الخطوات
التي تتم مع الجزائر هي خجوله الخطوات مع
الدول الافريقيه لاحظنا فان رواندا الرئيس
الفرنسي تحاشى حتى ان يقدم نقدا لما جرى
فرواندا بشكل عام فرنسا لم تقدم على خطوات
تاريخيه من شانها ان تشعر الافارقه ان
هنالك تغييرا عميقا في النظره الفرنسيه
للافارقه بشكل عام سواء كساسه او كمجتمعات
هذه واحده يمكن اخذ مثال المانيا اقدمت
على خطوه اعتذار وتعويضات مثل لنميبي عن
فترتها الاستعماريه فرنسا لحد الان لم
تقدم حتى حتى في الملف الجزائري ما زال
يتارجح هذا بعد هنالك ابعاد اخرى اعتقد
فرنسا بحاجه الى مراجعتها بعمق بعمق
فالوجود مثلا الهجره الافريقيه الكبيره
وهي اكبر هجره افريقيه موجوده في العالم
موجوده في فرنسا لكن هذه الهجره الافارقه
يعرفون فرنسا اكثر مما يعرفها الفرنسيون
انفسهم وعندما تريد فرنسا ان تتحدث الان
بلغه الرئيس ماكرون بنوع من الواقعيه من
الدول مع الدول
الافريقيه فالافائق الذين يعيشون في فرنسا
يعانون وجوها من العنصريه ويعاونون مشاكل
في التمييز ولذلك من الصعب على فرنسا ان
ان تغير سياستها فجاه دون ان تقدم على
خطوات عميقه سياساتها في المنطقه
المغاربيه بحاجه الى مراجعه عميقه فرنسا
لحد الان لم تظهر مؤشرات عميقه على
التغييرات في هذا الاتجاه ربما ليس فقط
المثال الجزائري وانما المثال ايضا مع
المغرب الان اكبر شريك لفرنسا في المنطقه
شمال افريقيا هو الان بصدد مراجعات
السياساتهم مع فرنسا وهكذا في جنوب في
جنوب الساحل وفي الصحراء في السنغال هنا
نعم بعد ايضا نتوجه الى الدكتور محمد
النظيف يوسف بنفس في نفس الاطار مساله
النجديه في العلاقات بين الجانب الفرنسي
وشركائه الافريقيين كما قال ضيفنا من
باريس هل من قبيل هذه النديه ان تودع اربع
عشره دوله افريقيه او خمسه عشره دوله
افريقيه تلك الدول التي تتعامل بما يسمى
بالسي اف ايه او الفرنك الافريقي هل من
النديه ام تودع مثل هذه البلدان نصف
احتياطياتها النقديه لدى الجانب الفرنسي
تخرج الاموال وتذهب الى فرنسا وتودع هناك
هل من قبيل النديه في العلاقات ان توضع
بعض دول غرب افريقيا 90% من احتياطات
احتياطياتها الذهبيه التابعه لبنوكها
المركزيه في الاعند الجانب الفرنسي هل هذا
من قبيل ان الضيئه من ينبغي اصلاح مثل هذه
الاختلالات في العلاقه بين الجانبين اولا
قبل الحديث عن شراكه حقيقيه
هذه ليست نديه بالتاكيد لكن كيف ننطلق من
النظريه الى الى التطبيق
هذه الدول موضوع العمله المشتركه وموضوع
الائتمانات البنكيه هذه الدول مثلا الدول
وسط افريقيا دول سته سبعه او دول غربي
افريقيا
هذه المساحه لها ايجابيات كثيره في الواقع
منها اقتصاديه لان ربط هذه الدول كلها
الحركه الاقتصاديه هذا جانب ايجابي لكن
موضوع الانفكاك وموضوع الفرنسي فيحتاج الى
ترتيبات قويه هل الدول هذه نفسها الانيه
جاهزه لان تقوم بهذه العمليات الاقتصاديه
الكبيره لكنني اعتقد ان ملامح فرنسا تمتلك
اوراق كثيره هناك ملامح استراتيجيه اذا
انتهجتها ملامح جديده قبل ان ننتقل الى
فكره اخرى حينما تقول هل هذه الدول جاهزه
هذا يعني ببساطه شديده ان هذه الدول ليست
تامه الاستقلال ليست لها السياده الكامله
على مقدراتها الماليه والاقتصاديه
لا الدول هذه عند استقلال من الستينات لكن
يعني هذه المشاكل يعني كل عيوبنا كل
مشاكلنا حروبنا كلها نقول فرنسا هي
المسؤوله نحن ايضا مسؤولون جزء من من
كيميتنا من تنميتنا البلدان هذه لماذا
خلال 60 عاما حتى الان ما في تطور كبير
بعض البلدان ما فيها الكهرباء بعض في امن
هذه المناطق حتى الكونغو زار الرئيس امس
هذه في
مناطقها حروب الناس يتقاتلون اذا نحن ايضا
كفارقه سكان لنا مسؤوليه كبيره وان كان
هذا لعنه ان فرنسا عندها دور كبير في
موضوع حتى الدول حتى الان الاستقلال
الاقتصادي الحقيقي المفروض من البدايه
كمان تذكرت ذاك الرئيس عندما انتهج غير
النهج تعب كثيرا ولكننا
لكن رؤساء سابقين لبعض البلدان الافريقيه
لقوا حتفهم بعدما اعلنوا عن رغبتهم في
الاستقلال النقدي والاقتصادي والماليه عن
فرنسا يعني يمكن ان نذكر في هذا الصدد
رئيسي رئيسي توجو وبوركينا فاسو سابقين
لقوا حتفهم بعد قليل مما اعلنوا عنه او
بعد الاعلان عن نيتهم
الفكره التي يريد ان اقولها ان نحن ايضا
عندنا مسؤوليه كبيره وعليه لا بد من ان
نوجه سؤال نطرحه لفرنسا لابد من الاعتراف
هي نفسها
بالتنوع الثقافي وخصوصيه المجتمعات
الافريقيه
وكيف
اقحام الجانب التنموي الاقتصادي في
العلاقات بين فرنسا وافريقيا لابد الناس
ياتون ويجلسون كيف هذه العملات وهذه
السيفيه كيف انت تتطور هذه اشياء كلها
تحتاج لان هناك اتفاقيات عبر الزمان وعبر
فنحتاج الى جلوس
والفرنسيين فعلا لابد التفكير كما انتم
ذكرتم في موضوع
اكتساب النخب نخب جديده اخرى لان ما ممكن
هم ياتون وياخذون نخب ويتركون نقب اخرى
مثلا في تشاد او في الكاميرون
المثقفين باللغه العربيه لابد الفرنسيه
نتعاملون معهم حتى يكتسبون ودهم وكذلك
باللغه الانجليزيه في في الكاميرون وهكذا
تكون وجهه وفكره فنص شامله صحيح في الاونه
الاخيره لاول مره من خلال 60 عاما
الفرنسيين قبل فتره جمعوا الاساتذه
الجامعيين الناطقين باللغه العربيه وقال
لهم لابد ان يساعدون في البحث وهذه خطوه
اعتقد مهمه اذا لا بد من اعاده الاهتمام
حتى بدعم المؤسسات المجتمع المدني لان ما
ممكن انت تاتي فقط توجه المجتمع المدني
برساله معينه يجب ان يكون لك رساله شامله
للجميع في الشمال وفي الجنوب في اي دوله
في الغرب حتى الناس يشعرون بان فرنسا
تقدم النظريه الى تركيا بشكل كبير ماذا
اعدت رؤيه ماكرون الجديده للبلدان
الافريقيه من اجل تنميه تلك البلدان حتى
اللحظه الرهينه رغم مرور عشرات الاعوام
عقود كثيره في العلاقات بين فرنسا
وشركائها الذين يستخدمون حتى الفرنك
الافريقي والذين يودعون نصف احتياطياتهم
النقديه لدى فرنسا حينما نجد او ننظر الى
مستوى المعيشه في تلك البلدان والاقتصاد
نجدها من ضمن افقر بلدان افريقيا رغم كل
هذه هذا التاريخ الطويل من العلاقات مع
الجانب الفرنسي هل هناك خطط لدى ماكرون
لاحداث تنميه حقيقيه في تلك البلدان بما
يرفع من مستوى معيشه المواطن
يبدو ان هناك حديث عن ماض قد انتهى وولى
فانا من جيل لا ما اعرف كل هذه الاشياء
السابقه التي تحدثتم عنها نحن الان بعيدون
جدا عن هذه الممارسات السابقه ولابد لابد
ان نستمر بالقول هذه الامور ايضا تذكرتم
مثال
الفرنسيين يعني عذرا على المقاطعه عذرا
على المقاطعه
عذرا على المقاطعه ارجو ان تنصت اليه
كلامك هذا يعني قد يفهم منه التقليل من
حجم الاخطاء او الخطايا التي ارتكبت من
قبل فرنسا مع شركائها في افريقيا يعني
الماضي الاستعماري هذا اذا كنت ترى انه
شيء بسيط وهين بالنسبه لك وبالنسبه لجيلك
الذي لم يشهد هذه الفتره فانه تقريبا كل
[موسيقى]
هذه
القرارات والاجراءات وهناك عمل كبير اتخذ
جرى في فرنسا خاصه بالتعاون مع الافارقه
وفي
تعاملنا مع الجزائر هناك مؤرخ قد تعجره
تعييني لدراسه هذا التاريخ
والتحديدا مسؤوليات كل الطرف وهذا العمل
ايضا قمنا به مع روندا وادى ايضا الى الى
اعتراف عادل بالمسؤوليات كل طرف من
الطرفين
وايضا انت تتحدث عن هذه النقود اموال التي
فعلا ادت الى ثقافه التعامل بين البلدين
فرنسا لطالما قالت ان ان المسؤوليه
مسؤوليه الافارقه ان يقولوا ما الذي
يريدونه لمستقبل هذه العمله وان فرنسا قد
انسحبت من
المؤسسات الماليه
احيانا ما ينتظر من فرنسا هو اقوى مما هو
ينتظر من دول اخرى وان فرنسا في الواقع
مستعده جدا للتطور والتعاون في عده كثير
مواضيع
ولكن الافريقيين وليفرض عليهم اي شيء
نعود الى السؤال الاساسي هل هناك يعني اله
اهميه خاصه لمساله التنميه مع الشركاء
الافريقيين في رؤيه ماكرون الجديده
نعم فعلا نحن في الواقع
بل نستعمل مصطلح الشراكه الاقتصاديه لان
عملنا عشكل الصداقات نتصدق بها وبالتالي
فان
وبالتالي فانه في طريقه تسميه الامور لم
نعد نتحدث عن تنميه عن شراكه اقتصاديه
الطرفان يستفيدان فيها ويفوزان وفرنسا
داود طبعا تحقق مصالحها في افريقيا وتقول
الافارقه لماذا هذه الشراكه هي مفيده
للطرفين
وايضا العمل بطريقه متوازنه لان افريقيا
في لديها مصادر كثيره وثروات كثيره في
الواقع مفيده من اجل الانتقال البيئي
وايضا هذه الشراكه هي فيها الطرفان يفوزان
وفيها عوده اقتصاديه
مفيده لافريقيا وهذا سيكون شقيقه مفتوحه
وتجنن ان هناك تمثلنا قوه اخرى في افريقيا
هنا الروس والصين وكيف ان هناك اهتمام
بافريقيا وعدم احترام
للبيئه الافريقيه والسكان في حين ان فرنسا
موقفها عكس ذلك سيد منصف السليمي اذا
اتينا كما يعني من حيث انتهى ضيفنا اذا
بدانا من هذه النقطه مساله الوجود الصيني
المتزايد وكذلك النفوذ الروسي المتزايد في
القاره الافريقيه اذا كان الوضع كما يقول
ضيفنا هذه البلاد لا تحترم الخصوصيات
الثقافيه للافارقه كيف يمكن ان نفسر نمو
حجم التبادل التجاري مع دوله مثل الصين
لتصبح 18% تقريبا مع بلدان القاره
الافريقيه التي كانت دائره في الفلك
الفرنسي تقليديا مع تراجع الجانب الفرنسي
والتبادل التجاري مع الجانب الفرنسي
الاربعه في المئه فقط
بالتاكيد ان فرنسا تسجل تراجعا كبيرا على
المستوى الاقتصادي وحضورها التجاري
والاقتصادي في القاره الافريقيه رغم انها
ما زالت تحتفظ بادوار الاف شركات والكنصر
تيوم يعني في القاره الافريقيه في مجالات
اقتصاديه مختلفه لكن
خلينا نسميها زحف الاقتصاد الضخمه الذي
تقوم به الصين والذي
يعادل الاف المرات اكثر من الحضور
الاوروبي برمته وليس فقط الفرنسي هو نابع
ايضا عن نهج براجماتي صيني
انتهج سياسه مختلفه عن الدول الغربيه وهذه
السياسه مكنت الصين من الحضور الاقتصادي
في دول عديده افريقيه كانت لها او دخلت في
ديون كبيره مع الصين ودخلت في اشكاليات
ايضا اقتصاديه وكذلك الصين طريقه الديون
التي تعطيها والاستثمارات التي تقوم بها
هي سخيه جدا لكن
تعقبها ربما مشاكل هيكليه في المستقبل
لتلك الدول الافريقيه التي هي ليست محصنه
في استقلالها الاقتصادي بالمقابل فانه
بموازاه ذلك هنالك منافسه روسيه شرسه على
المستوى العسكري على مستوى مجموعات مرتزقه
الفاجنر وكذلك على مستوى العلاقه مع انه
خبي العسكريه اعتقد ان فرنسا المشكله
الرئيسي انها في مرحله تحاول اعاده
موضوعها وانتشارها اقتصاديا وعسكريا
وسياسيا في القاره الافريقيه في مرحله
القاره تشهد فيها تطور كبير وفي مرحله
فيها منافسه كبيره ولكن فرنسا لا تمتلك كل
المقومات لاعاده نفوذها بشكل كبير ما لم
يتم تنسيق اكبر مع الدول الاوروبيه
وشركائها الغربيين فرنسا ربما بسبب انشغال
الدوله مثل المانيا او بسبب تضارب
السياسات مع ايطاليا وغيرها ومع اسبانيا
فال الاوروبيه تبدو فاقده للتنسيق فيما
يتعلق بالسياسه الاقتصاديه دعنا نرى مثلا
مشكله الهجره لان مشكل الهجره في عمق هو
مشكل تنموي ومشكل استقرار في الدول
الافريقيه بينما في الحقيقه الامر الدول
الاوروبيه تنفع ثمن تقصيرها في هذه في هذا
الملف
ومتوقع ان تزداد هذه الاشكاليه عمقا بسبب
تغير المناخ بسبب الاشكالات المترتبه عن
عدم الاستقرار الاقتصادي والسياسي في تلك
والامن في البلدان الافريقيه اعتقد ان
فرنسا
ينبغي ان يعاد ربما النظر في
استراتيجياتها بحاجه الى مزيد التنسيق مع
الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى حتى داخلين اعتقد ان الرئيس ماكرون
وهو من النخب بالفرنسيه الشابه الذي ولد
بعد فتره الاستعمار وهو متحمس لمجموعه من
الافكار ويريد حتى ادخال التغييرات في
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه من الناحيه الداخليه
وهذا يؤثر على اداء فرنسا وهنالك تضارب
داخلي بين الكيدرسي وبين
وبالتالي فان اداء فرنسا يبدو مذبذبا في
مرحله صعبه جدا واذا لم تستيقظ
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه والنظر الامور
بواقعيه اكبر مما يتحدث عنه الرئيس ماكرون
فان حظوظ استعاده نفوذها فرنسا في المناطق
الافريقيه المختلفه حدود ضعيفه والدليل
على ذلك مثلا منطقه شمال افريقيا منطقه
المغرب العربي كيف خسرت فرنسا موقعها في
ليبيا كيف
تتخبط الان امام المعادله الجزائريه
المغربيه كيف تبدو تواجه انتقادات شديده
بسبب سياستها في تونس اعتقد ان الامور في
غرب افريقيا وتحديدا في دول الساحل
والصحراء هنالك معضله كبيره تواجه الوجود
الفرنسي هنالك والروس يتقدمون والمؤلم جدا
ان الدول الافريقيه بسبب عدم وجود حصانه
داخليه في سيادات هذه الدول وفي توجهاتها
فان نزوع بعض النخب نحو
التغم العسكريه والسيطره عبر الانقلابات
على الحكم وهذا تدفع ثمنه في حقيقه الامر
القاره الافريقيه ولا تبدو فرنسا بمفردها
علق قلعه المستوى الاوروبي والغربي مؤهله
لاستعاده دور
استراتيجي كبير اعتقد ان فرنسا يعاني اكثر
في المرحله المقبله طالما لم تستعد
انفاسها دكتور محمد النظيف يوسف
ثلاث من الدول الافريقيه الاربعه التي
زارها الرئيس ماكرون مؤخرا
صوتت ضد مشروع قرار في الامم المتحده يدعو
القوات الروسيه او يدعو روسيا الى
الانسحاب من اوكرانيا رغم ان هذه البلدان
يفترض انها
تحتفظ بعلاقات قويه مع الجانب الفرنسي
الذي بطبيعه الحال يدعم مثل هذه القرارات
الامميه كيف نفسر هذا هل ترى تراجعا
يتواكب مع تراجع النفوذ الاقتصادي والمالي
الفرنسي في افريقيا تراجعا سياسيا ايضا
لا هناك تطور الانسان الافريقي ليس هو
الانسان في السبعينات او الثمانينات حاليا
افريقيا فيها 4000 جامعه كم من الخريجين
والمثقفين والذي رجع من فرنسا ليس الطريق
كما هي التقليديه التبعيه العمياء هكذا
هناك وعي فعلا من الافارقه ولكنني انا
اعتقد ان هذه الاخطاء كلها فرنسا هي التي
تركت هؤلاء الناس من غير
حوار من غير هيكله حقيقيه لعلاقتها ما هذه
الدول وبالتالي الروس جاؤوا والصيني جاؤوا
وهؤلاء عندهم برنامج جاؤوا فلذلك لابد اذا
طلبوا منه شيء عندهم برامج تنمويه بعدين
يساهمون في اشياء في الواقع في بعض
الاحيان تخدم الشعاب بناء البرلمانيات
المؤسسات البرلمانيه مؤسسات تهم الجميع
لذلك الدول هذه في بعض الاحيان ترى
مصالحها في المقام الاول لذلك اعتقد بان
فرنسا لابد من حتى انا اعتقد في بعض
الاحيان موضوع الوجود القوات الفرنسيه قد
يكون له جوانب ايجابيه في بعض الاحيان لكن
لابد من الهيكله الجديده
موضوع التدريب والتاهيل ليس فقط
محطه عسكريه هكذا لكن لابد من تحويلها الى
مؤسسه فنيه لوجستيه هناك شراكه حقيقيه بين
الدول حتى الدول هذه جيوشها تتقوى
وفرنسا لابد من ان تفكر
مليا في موضوع الشراكات الحقيقيه حتى
موضوع الفرانكفونيه لابد من نقل هذه
المنظمه مجرد فقط دعم للغه الفرنسيه لكن
تتحول الى منظمه اقتصاديه الى منظمه
تنمويه وبهذه الطريقه
الناس يقدر يحترفوا فرنسا ويقدروا يوقفوا
في مواقفها وموضوع الذي ذكره الاخ قبل
قليل لا يمكن فرنسا وحده الان لابد من
اقناع الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي في تعزيز العلاقات
الافريقيه فرنسا العلاقات كثير من الدول
الاوروبيه ما عندها علاقات مع افريقيا لكن
هذا فضاء كبير لا بد من الاتحاد الافريقي
ايضا ان يكون بجانب فرنسا تكون هناك شراكه
حقيقيه لتنميه افريقيا حتى ممكن بعد ذلك
تواجه بعض الادوار المتعلقه بروسيا الان
زي ما انت تقول لا تصوتوا لروسيا روسيا
جاءت واقناعته في بعض الامور سيد تومه
المتبقي من ولايه ماكرون الثانيه هو اربع
سنوات فقط هل هذه المده كافيه لانزال
افكاره ورؤيته لشراكه مع افريقيا تقوم على
اسس من التعاون واستعاده فرنسا نفوذها
التقليدي هل هذه المده كافيه لاحداث هذا
التغيير
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي هذا الدليل مره اخرى على ان
فرنسا موجوده وهي قد عبات الاوروبيين لكي
يصلوا الى افريقيا وبناء شراكه جديده
وانظروا مثلا الصين التي هي الدول التي
تساعد في كثيرا في سعاده الديون الافريقيه
وهي ليس في علاقه جيد جدا مثلا مع العمال
الذي يعملون لديها وانظر الى الروس ايضا
شراكتهم اساسيه تقوم اساسا تقوم على
امن الانظمه الحاكمه وهي قد تكون انظمه
غير شرعيه
واذكركم
المقاطعه مره اخرى يعني اكره مقاطعتك سيد
قاسيو
سيد قاسيو اكره مقاطاعتك مره اخرى لكن
حينما تتحدث عن دعم انظمه قد تكون انظمه
غير شرعيه في افريقيا من قبل روسيا والصين
يعني كانك تتحدث
وتتغافل تماما عن تاريخ فرنسا البليء بمثل
هذه التصرفات يعني في غير محطه تاريخيه
قامت فرنسا بارتكاب افعال افقع من هذه
بكثير وانت قلت قبل قليل ان هذا الامر غير
مهم غير مهم الحديث عن هذا الامر لاننا من
جيل لم يشهد مثل هذه الممارسات
نعم بالضبط انا اتحدث عن ممارسه الفرنسيه
قد تكون موجوده في الزمن الماضي ولكن في
الواقع الاستعمار جديد تقوم به روسيا
انظروا مثلا ان السلطات افريقيا
الوسطى
العمل تحت ضغوط كثيره من مرتزقه
نحن في فرنسا نحترم دائما اراده رغبه
القاده الافارقه مثلا الرؤساء المسؤولون
الماليون لطالم
قطع علاقتهم مع التعاون هم مع فرنسا
وافقنا على ذلك وبالتالي
اما اما الذين لديهم ضرر من عذر ايضا
علاقه روسيا باوكرانيا واليس هذا وجود
تصرف الاستعمار الجديد بفضل الامور بالقوه
في حين فرنسا اليوم ليس لديه اي نيه
استعماريه وفقط تريد ان تحقق
شراكه متوازنه مع دول ترغب بذلك سيد منصف
السليمي هل تصدق هذا الكلام
بالتاكيد يعني انه الامر يعني يتوقف على
الافعال ماذا تنجز الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
ولنقول الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه على على ارض
الواقع هل لكي نرى هل ان هذه الاماني او
التطلعات التي يعبر عنها الرئيس ماكرون
والتي يتحدث عنها الان عضو مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي هل هي تتحقق في الواقع ام لا
اعتقد ان هنالك صعوبه كبيره في تنفيذ او
في سير الامور في الواقع لان عدد من الدول
الافريقيه الان من الناحيه العسكريه ومن
الناحيه الاقتصاديه مثلا في منطقه غرب
افريقيا هي تتمرد على النفوذ الفرنسي وهو
مؤشر غير ايجابي اعتقد بالنسبه لفرنسا
ولاوروبا والمغرب بشكل عام ويتعين التوقف
عنه والبحث عن عن سيغ جديده للعلاقه بدون
القفز الى هذه نقطه نقطه ثانيه اعتقد انه
في المرحله المقبله ستكون فرنسا امام سؤال
جوهري هل بامكانها تغيير نوعيه العلاقه مع
الدول الافريقيه لقد اشار النائب الذي
تحدث من تشاد بشان اعاده الهيكله اعتقد
انه اعاده الهيكله عندما تكون فيه علاقه
فقط بين فرنسا وتلك الدول الافريقيه ينبغي
النظر للدول الافريقيه الان انها هي تنظر
الامور بمنظور جديد قائم على التعدد
الشراكات تعدد الشراكات ومنظور يتجاوز
النظره القديمه التي تحتكر فيها النفو
فرنسا النفوذ على الدول الافريقيه شكرا
جزيلا لك من مدينه بون في المانيا كان
معنا الكاتب الصحفي الاستاذ منصف السليمي
واشكر كذلك ضيفا من باريس توميجا سي
والنائب في البرلمان الفرنسي ورئيس لجنه
الدفاع الوطني فيه وكان معنا من مدينه
مدران في جنوب افريقيا الدكتور محمد
النظيف يوسف عضو البرلمانه تشاديه
والبرلمان عموم افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا كتاب حلقتنا الى هذا الاسبوع لقائنا
يتجدد مع حضراتكم الاسبوع المقبل مع موضوع
جديد
وسيناريوهات جديده
[موسيقى]